pagnol inédit chez carrère vertiges ou
vertige carrière je produis comme on dit
jacqueline pagnol commanditant career
verte' carrière d'artiste ma première
version était la bonne et à côté de moi
et à côté de vous daniel auteuil que je
suis ravi de recevoir sur son plateau
mais je veux toujours me à cette
émission tu veux jamais j'avais grave à
s'affaler sur les choses qui vont
s'affirmer et je voudrais que vous
accueillez jacqueline pagnol et daniel
auteuil avec le mérite il aurait dû
alors pagnol inédit jacqueline c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire
le terme inédit et oui parce que ce sont
des textes qui n'ont jamais été publiés
et puis c'est aussi ce sont aussi des
textes auxquels on s'attendait peut-être
pas à 10 tout comme moi oui bien entendu
vous avez raison son sujet de
conversation au quotidien à table quand
nous avions des amis c'était à peu près
ce genre de type de conversation c'est
extraordinaire c'est que c'est qu'il ya
un peu une démystification de toutes les
choses qui nous entourent sûr j'ai pas
aussi bien mathématiques que les
sciences que les rapports humains que
les animaux de la forêt alors que bon
pagnol c'est plutôt quand même la
provence le seul est justement mon fils
m'a dit j'en ai assez de voir mon papa
série
marine est constamment dans l'huile
d'olive et les herbes de provence je
veux qu'on découvre un pagnol
réel c'est un peu pessimiste oui jean
jacques gauthier 10 et de l'iss enfin il
avait fait le portrait d'un optimist
angoissé et lucide c'est réussit
décidément rester mais je suis pas y
parle de deux choses on n'a pas
l'habitude de deux d'entendre parler
mais avec beaucoup beaucoup d'humour un
progrès c'est la reconnaissance d'une
erreur les progrès de la science sont
immenses c'est à dire que ces erreurs
ont été énormes
les progrès le progrès continu c'est la
preuve qu'une erreur est remplacée par
une autre erreur qui cédera son tour la
place à une autre erreur notre seul
espoir c'est que les erreurs de nos
savants sont peut-être de moins en moins
nombreuses et qu'elles se rapprochent
peu à peu de la vérité ouais cessé il ya
une petite pointe d'optimisme enfin ses
doudounes et là c'est un gars dur
surtout que les shows oui sur le chant
du rossignol va donc tout le monde dit
le chant du rossignol c'est pas évident
mais dit d'abord que le rossignol c'est
très bon à manger aux très bas et m'a
grave et que le chant du rossignol nous
emmerdent consommer d'eau parce que nyon
l'entente parce qu'on allait tel aviv
mais que le paysan que celui qui habite
la campagne est tout à fait blasé sur le
signal est ce que vous avez eu du mal à
sortir ce livre est ce que vous êtes pas
dit quelque part il ya un peu une
peut-être trahison oui parce qu'au
départ ce n'était pas destiné à étudier
non c'est un câble et monfils a beaucoup
insisté puis je trouve qu'il avait
raison parce que c'est découvrir un
autre abcès de de marcel j'ai un peu
hésité j'ai un peu hésité mais je trouve
que j'ai bien fait j'ai reçu beaucoup de
témoignages en me disant tu as très bien
c'est vous avez très bien c'est quoi
c'est rétablir une
une vérité que d'établir un pagnol
inconnue tout à fait différent est ce
que dans la vie il était comme comme là
où il était plus il était plus comme
comme dans ce livre où est-ce qu'ils
étaient plus comme dans une camisole
conconi lille était un mélange d'aidé
c'est à dire aussi bien qu'à sang à
sétif que ça s'en ressent d'illusions
alors quel est le thème à vous qui vous
plaît le plus dans ce bouquin est ce que
c'est les sciences la fonction
respiratoire ce qu'ils s'intéressent
c'est beaucoup en fonction se mirent à
noir ça a l'air comme ça très très ardue
mais c'est très drôle
il ya beaucoup de chiffres a quand même
ya beaucoup de si et des opérations et
du calme
c'était effectivement c'est une
découverte pour mendier un petit peu
plus quand même ça vous dire est ce que
vous avez fait un choix de textes
est-ce que vous en avez mis beaucoup
beaucoup de côtés c'est mon fils qui a
fait tout ça avec la dir l'éditeur mme
6,6 millions et qui ont fait le choix
que j'ai revu après bien entendu avec
mon beau-frère sonné et nous avons
choisi les textes définitifs mais on a
presque tous gardés est ce que je sais
est ce que ça vous plaît plus de dire ça
parce que vous n'avez plus la pression
du duo espagnol que de lire bon dd est
vous qui a déjà édité ou non mon préféré
c'est jean de florette et manon des
sources et pas parce que daniel est là
non mais c'est parce qu'elle est là mais
on va dire que c'est vraiment une oeuvre
magnifique et puis qui a ramassé quand
même une nomination aux césars cette
année on peut demander un peu de
l'actualité
alors on va parler du alors la
nomination c'est meilleur film meilleur
réalisateur donc le berry meilleur
acteur daniel auteuil ça vous fait
plaisir
rhys meyer des rôles féminins emmanuelle
béart meilleur scénario claude berri et
gérard brac musique jean claude petit
photo bruno nuytten sont pierre gamay et
dominique hennequin et la fiche pour
michel jouin c'est vous attendiez à ce
que l'otan de nomination moi je
m'attends jamais rien moi je suis d'une
grande prudence j'attends je le suis non
je suis tombé comme ça
une bonne année une bonne année c'est
lens qui m'a vraiment aussi fait plaisir
c'est que 14 millions de gens ont
découvert ou redécouvert pagnol à
travers ces deux films c'est vrai que ça
a été un événement extraordinaire c'est
un monaco se finir et pour vous de le
faire ça a dû être un événement j'ai eu
une carrière
oui vous indépendamment du résultat oui
oui non c'est s&s et c'était là la
chance d'avoir de rencontrer un auteur
justement d'en rencontrer pagnol et je
veux dire tant que je pourrai je me
mettrai au service de pagnol parce que
c'est pas c'est le moins je lui dois
quand même satisfaite et content de
s'être ugolin la forme il va jouer une
autre oeuvre de marcel
on avait envie au oui bien sûr bien
entendu alors il ya des choses
formidables donc je tiens quand même
conseillé ce pagnol inédit chez vertige
car et les choses comme ça son principe
de l'appareil par exemple un an
un homme normal respire 15 fois par
minute à chaque temps respiratoires il
expire 0,1 1,5 cent des ruses et il
espère 015 sander 90.5 100 x 15 et gad 7
litres
sept mille cinq cents la minute soit 458
alors il avait quand même des comme ça
tout d'un coup il se penchait sur la
trique et public ayem est une folie et
une folie il fonde de folie du ctu à qui
me fait penser à jean de florette si
jamais tout à fait ça oui deux jambes
sont là le goût d'aider des chiffres des
nombreux mais c'est drôle en plus moi je
trouve que le fait de sortir à bout de
ces chiffres en l'air bon c'est oui
parce qu'en plus c'est fait avec humour
et en plus c'est drôle
voilà c'est à dire qu' il peut c'est
dommage qu'il ait pas enseigner les
mathématiques parce que j'aurais été un
bon élève
voici la lah en lisant ça moi aussi je
me sens très bien le pédagogue
n'oubliez pas que marcel a été
professeur d'anglais dans leur ensemble
les pédagogues
oui le pédalo voulu mettre deuxième
degré il était comme ça avec ses élèves
paraît-il désagréable jacqueline pagnol
vous remercie d'être venus sur cette
émission vous restez un petit peu avec
longchair daniel avait tellement content
que vous allez voir vous savez que quand
vous êtes la voix c'est le temps que
vous voulez le viatique charlie je la
paye et alors on va passer de suite à la
suite avec la nouveauté ne bougeait pas
lâcher